[Music]
[Applause]
tj quinn thank goodness our business has
tj quinn espn investigative reporter
senior writer
and he's been covering the brittany
griner situation in russia i don't even
know if you can call it a situation
feels like it's more than that but let's
go back here tj to how many years has
brittany griner been playing basketball
in russia
oh several you gotta hit me with the one
i didn't have right at my fingertips um
it's been a number of years and she's
one of many players from the wnba who've
been
making sometimes four or five times
their wnba income playing for teams over
there
she was making about a million dollars a
year i think um
at what point did this
become i guess she was going through
security well walk me through what
happened and and how britney griner
ended up in the situation where she is
yeah i think people forget that the the
invasion of ukraine hadn't started yet
it was february 17th and yes people knew
that there were you know some dangerous
things going on in that part of the
world she and other players who've been
going over there have been doing so
under the protection of
these oligarchs who own these teams i
mean it's like going into a bad
neighborhood with a gang or a mob boss
saying hey she's okay you knew you had
certain protections well as soon as the
war starts and
all the sanctions are put into place
against those oligarchs that
protection's gone so but she was walking
through on february 17th
and she gets stopped they say that she
had vape cartridges with hashish oil in
them
uh her side actually hasn't said
anything publicly and we haven't heard
her make an actual plea in court
um
but you know it took a good three weeks
for news to even get out in the united
states that she'd been in captivity
is is the charge drug trafficking
the charge is uh yeah trying to
smuggle drugs into the country they've
got very strong drug laws to them it's a
it's a big cultural issue
and she is facing under this up to 10
years but
you really can't look at it as a regular
legal proceeding she is a chit in a
negotiation right now they will go
through the pantomime of making this a
real legal proceeding it is not i've
spoken to i don't know how many experts
uh people at the u.s state department um
the fact is russia does this they it's
it's all negotiation it's transactional
this is not about justice
um so in the end it as far as russia
goes it doesn't matter she did it or not
they're gonna deal for her
um if she happened to do what they said
fine if she didn't whatever they'll come
up with some evidence that
uh
you know during this trial it's about to
start they will have some kind of
evidence it could be completely made up
it could be absolutely valid but it
doesn't matter it's a negotiation does
she have representation on the ground
with her in russia
she's got her own lawyers and the people
around her that i've talked to and at
the state department say they're legit
they're good you don't want a public
defender in russia a public defender is
seen as an extension of the prosecution
they're they work with the prosecution
and it's
you know it's an it's an old play for
them to
you know when you when you want
something you you plant drugs on
somebody or you make an accusation about
drugs
um
the fact that she is a six foot nine
black lesbian is is not something lost
on the russian public or government
she's a powerful cultural symbol and
they recognize that
um
so
you know she's
could she face 10 years she'll probably
get that sentence everyone is expecting
her to be convicted and sentenced but
they also see it as it's just a
negotiating tool how do people get
involved who can get involved
you know the commissioner can't do
anything like is this the white house
it comes down entirely to the white
house and the state department
are they willing to cut a deal russia
has already floated it i mean this this
was pretty interesting how how open they
were about it
um there was a story in tess and those
of us who grew up you and me who grew up
in the cold war remember tasks well it's
it's the state news agency anything they
say it's because the kremlin said this
is okay
they put out a story in may saying that
uh it had been discussed a possible
trade for her and a russian man named
victor boot who's in a u.s prison for
financing terrorism they've tried to get
boot out before somebody wants him to
come home to russia
but once they once task put out there it
was very clear okay this is this is a
deal they want and now it's up to what's
the us willing to do what kind of deal
will they cut and there's a big split in
the government about it you've got
people in the state department who say
look the incentive to kidnap an american
is already there you're not going to
create more incentive just cut the deal
bring her home but there are others
saying well no this is it's going to put
other americans at risk if if they know
we're going to make a deal that easily
other people are going to grab
the other complication is that there's
another american there paul whelan who's
been there for three years he was
convicted in what the u.s calls a
ridiculous show trial for espionage
um and the by demonstration knows and
the kremlin surely knows politically you
can't bring one of them home and not the
other so from what i understand they're
trying to get a deal to get both of them
her
detention's been extended another six
months to december 20th
what reason
because they can't um
you know it's they've got well under i
mean in this in this case it's not that
different from us law that you can hold
someone in a pre-trial detention period
for a long time and they under russian
law
can hold her for a year under
extraordinary circumstances they can
extend that to 18 months without taking
her to trial they've already set the
date um
but again the numbers don't mean
anything she is there completely at the
whim of putin's government
have you tried to go over
uh since this started
not a chance no um i mean this the state
department um
has a do not travel order um i've been
over there before it's um it's pretty
intense place um especially if you're a
journalist
um i had someone this is four years ago
i had someone in u.s intelligence say
look they think all our reporters are
spies because all their reporters are
spies and if you go over there you will
be surveilled don't try to detect it
don't try to avoid it they'll treat that
as tradecraft and then they'll treat you
like a spy
but right now it'd be a very bad idea
for anybody to go over there how close
have you come to speaking to brittany
griner
uh not even remotely um no nobody in her
family has either i mean they
saw that news last week that they had
finally set up a phone call with their
wife sherelle and the state department
fell on its sword and said no we that
call didn't happen because we didn't
have somebody manning the office where
that needed to happen
from what i'm told it still hasn't
happened they've been exchanging letters
her lawyers bring
correspondence to and from her um
knowing that it is every bit of it is
monitored but they're able to see her a
couple times a week so the people around
here her comfortable okay we know
you know she's okay
she's being held in detention is this
house detention or is she in a prison
no she's in a jail she um she's
requested house detention a number of
times
um but if you look at in terms of a
negotiation they're not going to do
anything to make comfortable um
i i anything that i get from people
around her and the state department have
got to take with a grain of salt i mean
they don't want to inflame this they've
got this balance of
they they want to keep attention on her
because it's an american in custody but
they don't want to put so much on her
that it makes her more valuable as a
chit to russia
um you know she is a pawn essentially so
um
you know the the correspondence is is is
is minimal um but it's out you know and
she's in a jail and it's not
from what i've heard of russian jails
they're they're not a fun place to be
but the reports of that she's okay
considering
i'm guessing other wnba players
not going to be going back to russia
anytime soon
for a couple reasons uh one i mean why
would you after this but also the money
is probably not going to be there
because all these oligarchs who were
willing to spend you know millions upon
millions
um to have these teams um i mean there
have been
suggestions uh that they use these teams
for money laundering but also as these
vanity pieces they they have these teams
they want them to do well they're
willing to spend money way beyond the
market
um they're not going to have the assets
that they did because they've been
frozen internationally um
you know but you but you do have to look
at other countries as well uh like
turkey um you know places where you've
got you know questionable governments um
just like the conversation we're having
about you know saudi arabia and
men's golf right now
oh man
yeah if this is a different female
athlete is the coverage different if let
let's say this was a
uh
i don't know uh
a soccer player um tennis player would
it if it's mia ham if it's serena
williams if it's simone biles um
is it different yeah i mean i've
wondered that as well um
it's
probably um
you know
people keep making the comparison what
if this were lebron james what if this
were tom brady it's not i mean she is
great in her sport unquestionably the
wnba doesn't have the audience in this
country that those sports do but there
are female athletes who rise to that
level yeah if it was serena williams
it's a much bigger deal and then you
can't help you know but
you know
see some kind of huge public reaction to
it um
you know you can understand her
supporters saying wait a second why are
we treating making a bigger deal out of
this
um there are a number of reasons um
and there's a there's no i don't i don't
want to
reveal anything she hasn't published yet
but like there's an academic who's an
expert in this who has talked about this
this concept of deservingness when
somebody is over there and how that what
that has to do with with their reaction
that if if the american public feels
like somebody is there because
um it was their choice um if they don't
you know if it's somebody who's utterly
uncontroversial they feel differently
more sympathetic
than someone like brittany griner you
know people are aware that she posted
protested the anthem um you've got an
unbelievably divided political climate
in this country and so there's half the
country right there saying
and i see it in my twitter feed anytime
there's any news about her let her stay
there let her you know if she wants to
protest
so you don't have the kind of general
consensus behind her i think you would
if it were another athlete but her
supporters say this is ridiculous this
is an american who's over there
um with a system that is
you know well known to be corrupt that
frames people why aren't we making a
bigger deal about this i think they have
a point what's the worst case scenario
worst cases they keep her there a long
time and that can happen like paul
whelan has been there for more than
three years
um
trevor reed a former marine who was just
released in may he'd been there more
than two years
for what was i mean
every account of it was they they
convicted him for they said he assaulted
a police officer the evidence they
brought was absolutely ridiculous
um but it still took more than two years
to bring him home and that wasn't until
his parents said that he had untreated
tuberculosis and had been severely
injured and the government our
government said we've got to do
something to get him out and they traded
a guy who who you know we'd had in jail
it could be years if they decide that
it's yours
tj thank you we appreciate you covering
it and thanks for joining us any time
thanks dan that's tj quinn espn
investigative reporter senior writer